it's great to welcome to the program
today richard griffiths who's president
of the georgia First Amendment
foundation an organization that's
dedicated to encouraging open government
free expression and independent
journalism so great to talk to you
Richard really appreciate you for having
me so listen we've been talking at the
federal level about what I've been
seeing as red flags when it comes to
press freedom and this a lot of it has
been coming from The Oval Office it
includes everything from threats of
making it easier to sue media outlets
journalism licenses refusal of interview
or even spots in the press room at the
White House based on the sort of
perceived friendliness to the
administration but it's not just at the
federal level that there are things
happening when it comes to press freedom
a lot of stuff as in many other areas
seems to be happening at the state level
is that right I would argue that that's
probably true too although there's
probably less chance for traction at the
state level although you can certainly
throw up a lot of impediments or yeah
well I was going to say the ethics in
journalism Act specifically in Georgia
is something that many people probably
have not heard of but which would have a
significant impact on on journalists
work well this was a bill dropped right
at the end of the legislative session it
became public on the 2nd of April which
was the last day and was filed on the
1st and I thought it was an April Fool's
joke initially but what it proposed was
a journalism oversight board a board
appointed initially by the Chancellor of
the University of Georgia the board to
be based at the very prestigious Grady
College of Journalism at UGA to be made
up of three editors three news producers
two web journalists and one retired
journalism professor and the bill
suggests that the folks there the nine
folks would create a Canada
standards for journalism and accredit
journalists within the state and enforce
the professional standards for
journalism in the state the bill would
also require that all outtakes from
interviews such as this one would have
to be provided to the interviewee within
three days of a request so outtakes
interview notes all photographs
it's sort of an a harassment measure
against existing journalism and and in a
not-so-subtle dig at journalists the the
bill would require that the journalists
turn over the outtakes and photographs
within three days which is precisely the
same period that government in Georgia
has to respond to the Open Records Act
there's no way thankfully that this bill
will pass at least I don't think it can
pass and even if it did pass the
governor of Georgia has said that he
won't sign it and I doubt there would be
enough votes to sustain it but it does
present a really interesting insight
into what I described as the zeitgeist
now in the country now this bill was
proposed by six really well-educated
people who are respected in the
legislature there's a former missionary
who also works as a contractor there's a
pharmacist there's a doctor a lawyer a
retired county agent whose chair of the
Education Committee and there's a real
estate development developer behind this
they're all Republican there as I said
well thought of they come from
predominantly rural areas and ten years
ago they would have been the
laughingstock for push
like this now I think the tone has
changed so much such that there's such
on the Republican side such disdain for
mainstream media that they have a pastor
do it and probably when they went back
to their districts they got slaps on the
backs and attaboys and that that is a
really disturbing trend if you if you
look at the latest Edelman Trust trust
survey that that came out in January
it's a global survey with an amazing
point six margin of error and in the
u.s. 69% of Democrats said to trust the
media but only 23% of Republicans now
that is a startling disconnect and
that's the thing that scares me the most
here and really is why bills like this
can come up and get traction yeah I mean
there's this earlier in the program we
talked about about this in regard to the
debate that is going on as to whether
children who are being kept in what are
effectively large cages at the border
deserve soap and bedding where there's a
creeping normalization if twenty years
ago you try to jump right to that part
of the debate you get no traction
whatsoever but over time as the sort of
Overton Window is pushed a little more
and more in a particular direction then
all of a sudden it seems at least in
some circles reasonable to debate
something like the accreditation of
journalists well I think this is not
just a u.s. issue I do a lot of work in
Eastern Europe helping news
organizations their deal with threats
against their operations and
particularly in Poland you see efforts
there to control the press and and there
it started with adjustments into the
constitution of the courts and who
could be a judge and how long one could
stay a judge so existing judges who had
lots of experience were removed and then
the judges who were put in were much
more hostile to a free press and they're
the independent journalists are under
assault for their ownership because some
of them are American own some of them
are half German partial German ownership
and so the attacks come as a sort of a
licensing component but it is all about
the threat to the government that
independent journalism presents and when
the government in question is hanging on
by a thread as is the case in Poland
they have a very narrow majority so the
efforts to constrain the press become
more vigorous now I don't want to draw
too many comparisons to Georgia but
Georgia for the first time is a state in
play and I suspect that also comes as
part of it here you have folks who are
really wanting to pump up their base and
wanting to get folks really enthusiastic
and out of the polls and the media
frankly is the bogeyman for a lot of
Republicans and it's easy to charge
people up and and get people fired up by
attacking a free and independent press
yeah it's been incredibly successful to
use this fake news term to basically
become a catch-all for anything that
contradicts the pre-existing narrative
that may exist in some political circles
or that is critical of the current
administration and what's most
disturbing to me is not that this is
something that the current
administration has attempted but the
success that has come with it I mean you
know the number of tweets and YouTube
comments that I get daily saying that my
program is fake news is probably not
altogether surprising because whatever
is kind of in
the the insult of the day I am the
recipient of but the serious way in
which as you point out it has affected
particularly Republican voters into
believing that at some fundamental level
basic news reporting cannot be trusted
that partisan divide is what shows me
how effective it's been well I think
there's another thing that journalists
like us have to look at each other in in
the face and and say we have allowed
ourselves to become too siloed and part
of the breakdown and Trust is that we
have not necessarily have been as
transparent as we should be about our
processes they're saying what in what
sense do you mean well I think the the
the public often look at institute large
journalism institutions and they don't
know how the magic happens they don't
know the amount of work that goes into
reporting out a new story how many calls
got made how many documents were
examined how many FOIA requests were
made how many efforts were made to get
somebody who didn't speak to speak and
we're not transparent enough about that
process there's a terrific initiative
coming out of the University of Georgia
and Poynter the trustee news initiative
where they're actively working to coach
news organizations to push openness and
transparency even go so far in some
newsrooms
to open up their editorial meetings to
face book lives so people can see how
those editorial discussions go how is
the newspaper going to be stacked
tomorrow what's going to be the lead
story what stories are their choosing
and why are they choosing those stories
at CNN when I was there there was a lot
of action on our part towards explaining
why we did stories and how we did them
and what the process was for reporting
out those stories those are all the
kinds of things that
build trust but as I say earlier that's
it's one step it's not the total
solution we've got to figure out other
ways of winning back that trust I agree
100% I think the other side of this and
I'd be curious to hear your thought
about it in the limited time we have is
the lack of media literacy that we
increasingly have in this country I
recently adjunct taught a course on
critical thinking and new media at
Boston College and a huge component of
it was just explaining to students what
the differences are between something
like fake news and something like simply
that there is editorial bias in a story
and being able to distinguish between
news and opinion journalism
understanding that anonymous source
doesn't necessarily mean anonymous to
the journalists but it is a sources
identity that may be kept private
from the public perspective all of these
basic things to me seem to be completely
missing from education right now I
completely agree with that I teach at
the University of North Carolina each
year and there's an intro course that's
a big survey course taught by the Dean
that I helped with and those kids are
everything from pre-meds to future
journalism major to chemistry majors who
you know have to fill fulfill some
preliminary requirements and there's
very startled to hear that what
journalists actually do know the names
of sources precisely the point but also
you know we as journalists need to be
much more careful about how we identify
our guest is the person who's on the air
a reporter delivering a report yes or
like me somebody who's giving their
opinion on on on journalism based on
years of experience so I'm I'm certainly
an opinion person I'm not a reporter
although I played that role in my career
so
defying who we have on the air who the
people are in the stories providing
their expertise is absolutely critical
yes well on that note Richard Griffiths
is president of the Georgia First
Amendment Foundation and he has been
here giving us his opinion on the basis
that he has informed that opinion
personally and not here as a reporter
Richard really appreciate your time
today on this really important issue
thank you for having me on